[Music]
good evening this is great to see you
all here on a Monday night and packing
the house here at SF Jazz as many of you
have seen and I finally remember to
actually announce it last time we do
have receptions here on the mezzanine
after these events and they have a bar
that allows you to bring drinks into the
event which is awesome but and along
those lines I have a special
announcement tonight along the lines of
our salon project and that is that we
have hired a person for our bar and cafe
manager and it's a Jennifer Kaleo who
many of you might know from small hand
foods who makes all the amazing syrups
for bartenders here a few cocktail nerds
I just heard
clapping and she's actually she's here
tonight and I'm gonna have her come up
and explain to you a couple of the
drinks that she's made for tonight that
were inspired by tonight's talk Jennifer
come on
[Applause]
thank you so much for thank you so much
for having me it's a real pleasure to be
part of this organization
so as Xander said I've have a couple
cocktails that I'm making tonight and up
until the opening of our salon I'm going
to try to pair some cocktails with each
of the talks that we do so tonight
within the keeping of the theme I have
two cocktails one's called the
penicillin it's not it's not actually
one of my cocktails it's a gentleman
from New York from milk and honey named
Sam Ross who came up with this cocktail
with some smoky scotch lemon ginger and
honey kind of feels medicinal delicious
and then I'm also doing inspired by the
Pueblo jars that were found with
theobromine residue in them signifying
the the that chocolate had had arrived
to the to North America I am making a
spiced hot chocolate with tequila and
green chartreuse marshmallows and now
I've been making them up there and I
apologize because I was told that you
guys don't drink for him any cocktails
so I didn't I didn't make that much of a
batch and we're almost out already so
I'm sorry and next time I'll make more
but so I hope you enjoy thank you so
much Thank You Jennifer Anna I think
there's there's plenty of extra green
chartreuse marshmallows right yes so I
highly recommend just go steal a green
chartreuse marshmallow their most
amazing marshmallows you've ever had
even if you don't get the to the
chocolate so two other things I wanted
to mention about the salon tonight one
is that I I made an announcement a while
back that Brian Eno is going to be doing
the sound for the ambient sound for the
whole space he's also going to be doing
a video and sound installation in the
one small room that we have in the back
with a window with the view of Golden
Gate Bridge it's going to be kind of a
triptych version of 77 million paintings
with some custom versions of it just for
our space as well as the sound that'll
be
in that small room so it'll be a great
little space and we're still looking for
sponsors on the level to underwrite that
as well as that the sound system that
were we're now working on so if you if
you feel inspired please come and talk
to me about that the we're about two
hundred thousand dollars away from from
actually finishing all of our funding
but we are under construction we are
making hires I saw them trenching in all
of the plumbing just today and it's it's
really looking awesome I'm pretty
excited about it and we're going to be
able to we're gonna be able to have you
know really cool 60 to 80 percent kind
of salon style of events I know we have
at least one booked now with Adam Rogers
on his new book proof the science of
cocktails so we're gonna have we'll have
and things are not just cocktail related
but we also have a lot of great cocktail
related talks and and drink related
talks which I'm excited by the last
thing that I wanted to mention is our
challenge coins and some of you may know
that if if you have donated over $100 to
the salon you will have you should have
already received one of these challenge
coins in the mail and the history of the
challenge coin is a military tradition
and if if you were in a squad and you
showed up to a bar and you pulled out
your challenge coin for your squad if
the other members of your squad didn't
produce it then they had to buy drinks
and if they all produced it you had to
buy all of them drinks so tonight is
going to be the first challenge coin
event it's we're springing it on you if
you have your challenge coin you can see
Danielle and you can get a free coupon
for one of the drinks Jennifer just
mentioned tonight
and underneath five armrests to your
right you have to go to your right arm
rest there are five challenge coins
taped underneath them any finders
they're taped with black gaffers tape
they're pretty hard to find the right
behind your cup holder
anyone found one alright alright so
there's keep looking there's another
four out there there might be some empty
seats well no they're mostly in this
middle section here you guys don't have
any I don't think sorry so that is those
are all my announcements tonight please
do as we approach the end of the year
and you're looking for those donations
to go out for your various charities
please do consider the salon and the
last thing that I'm going to introduce
is the long short for tonight which is
actually comes to us from the the
Smithsonian and it's kind of an intro to
tonight's talk on some of the amazing 3d
work that that they're doing in scanning
all the 3d objects or at least a
selection of the 3d objects in the
Smithsonian that are kind of unvisited
[Music]
here we are at the American History
Museum I'm standing in front of the
gunboat Philadelphia
it was built in 1776 it was sunk that
same year by the British there were
eight in total that were built and those
eight are often thought of as part of
the beginning of America's Navy so we're
using a variety of 3d scanning tools
some long-range capturing the boat in
its entirety at sort of medium
resolution detail and other very high
resolution tools we're using to capture
some of the smaller bits of interest
the laser arm scanner has some very
accurate encoders in each joint and
those encoders can tell the computer the
exact position of this laser beam in
real time so as we're scanning
we could see that a bit of data popping
up on screen so we could see exactly
what we've captured in what we haven't
so for objects that are geometrically
complex or wherever there's really close
quarters this is the ideal tool and this
data is going to be used to support
research at the Smithsonian and it's
also going to be used as a public access
tool
[Music]
the gunboat itself is in very very close
quarters so even if you're able to come
to the Smithsonian in person you can
only see a small portion of it so that's
part of the reason we're documenting
this object in 3d so we'll take that 3d
model put that online so visitors from
the Smithsonian and also from around the
world could explore this object in ways
they simply could not even if they were
here in the gallery
we're here at Cornell University and
their team is allowing us access to
high-resolution micro CT scanner the
great thing about this technology is
that we're able to study the interior
and exterior geometry of an object in a
non-destructive process thing we're
thinking that maybe we could offset the
walls of the flower so this is an
exciting example of coevolution between
a quarry Anthes orchid and Neil Ossian
bees the male you're glossing being
falls into the bucket at which point it
swings to become wet and it won't be
able to fly out the same way it came in
its forced to travel out a small hole in
the back where pollen is exchanged onto
the mail you glossy and beam the mail
you glossing B now carries the scent of
the orchid which attracts female you've
lost seen bees for reproduction
so once we have the CT data of the
orchid we'll be able to understand more
thoroughly how the orchid and glossy and
B interact whether it's a rare orchid a
historic gun boat or an archeological
site we see a huge potential to discover
and diffuse knowledge through a variety
of 3d scanning methods
[Music]
and what we're really looking forward to
is the future watching this technology
develop and apply this technology to the
Smithsonian at a larger scale
[Music]
I love all this digital stuff but you
know objects have their own special
appeal I'm Stuart brand from long now
and let's be clear I adore of the
Smithsonian when I was in my early 20s
and hanging out in Indian reservations
and wanting to put together a multimedia
show called American deeds Indians I
found myself in the castle on the mall
behind the Rose window and Bill
sturdevant's office going through file
drawers of photographs of American
Indians back streams the whole
collective period of the Smithsonian
tomorrow afternoon
my wife Ryan Phelan who runs a long now
project called revive and restore is
going to be at the Smithsonian's
brand-new Laboratory of analytical
biology talking to the new head there
about possibly working with them on the
genetic restoration genetic revival
genetic rescue of endangered species and
extinct species and we look for some
collaboration there one of our most
beloved board members was once head of
the Smithsonian's American History
Museum Roger
Kennedy and indeed this book the
introduction is by the secretary of the
Smithsonian Wayne Clough he was here as
a Salt speaker just a couple of years
ago so goes on and tonight we got a
whole bunch of Smithsonian for you
Richard Kurin
thank you yeah that's about five pounds
of history in this in this book it's
really a pleasure to be here tonight
with you thank you for being here it's a
lovely Hall as if jazz I haven't been
here before so it's just a marvelous
marvelous venue tonight I'm going to
take you through a quick tour of the
smithsonian and the book how many people
here have been to the smithsonian okay
like a lot like probably most of you
okay so the Smithsonian you know started
in 1846 named after a guy Smithson James
Smithson illegitimate child of British
aristocracy okay so he's kind of little
peeved at the at the brits he was a
chemist he was a meteorologist and he
really believed he knew about Benjamin
Franklin he knew about Thomas Jefferson
he believed that something hell if you
couple knowledge and democracy you would
have a really progressive society now
coming from Brittany never visited the
United States he bet first on the French
Revolution didn't turn out so well and
in 1826 he writes a will leaving his
fortune to the people of the United
States to found in Washington an
institution dedicated to the increase in
diffusion of knowledge a very much an
Enlightenment kind of ideal ah a
wonderful ideal at that time his he
never visited his fortune was worth five
hundred eight thousand dollars which
would be about equivalent to a hundred
million today what happened the US
Congress headed to mate we just fought
two wars with the Brits did we take the
money or not
well it took Congress what 20 years to
decide but eventually we took the money
created the Smithsonian and now the
Smithsonian with its museums research
centers global presence houses about 137
million objects in the museum not a
chartreuse mushroom mush mush
marshmallow
we do have charge for his mushrooms by
the way and that doesn't count
photographs and and and miles and miles
of archives that would stretch from here
to the to the moon now in doing this
book I really took the idea that
publisher or there's a guy Neil
MacGregor who headed to the British
Museum he did a book a hundred objects
of world history is very popular BBC did
stuff on it really give people an
appreciation of the heritage of this
planet using the collection of the
British Museum so the publisher of that
set called me up said hey Richard how
about doing one on America and I said
look I'm the husband of a school teacher
you know elementary school publicly we
don't teach history anymore that
American history is something whether
you're this way that way politically
whatever history is something that binds
us there is an experience that we've
been through and how you feel about it
nonetheless it helps make us who we are
I think it's really important to do so I
said I would do it under one condition
they said what's the one condition I say
well you know McGregor had a hundred
objects we're Americans we need one
hundred and one
still no easy task as you can imagine
and I'm I could talk later about how he
got to the objects what I wanted to do
in the book and you know Stuart's
exactly right I mean there's a lot of
things with long now and the Smithsonian
that really tie and one of the things I
think is and I think Wayne Clough said
it when he was here my boss the
Secretary of the Smithsonian that the
Smithsonian is in the forever business I
mean we really are in the forever
business we think about that all the
time
so what I wanted to do in the book and
you know you telling a story of American
history when did it begin and when do
you end and so I felt it was important
to bookend the hundred and one objects
in the book with two very important ones
so I start out the first object in the
book they're number one is the burgess
shale burgess shale comes from about
five hundred million years ago
and it tells the story of fossilized
life on this continent this is what
Americans look like five hundred million
years ago
and biologists the Canadians that's it I
think we snuck American over there the
the so the these these shells biologists
evolutionary biologists have used these
shells they're almost an imprint they're
not hard shells they're not records of
hard shells of creature they really
capture the soft tissue they were
captured in silt and so they're a great
data set they're almost like a
prehistoric photograph of an explosion
of life during the Cambrian era so I
started off 500 million years ago and I
ended the last object number 101 is a
telescope that we are now building in
Chile now I don't know if this thing
points you see the arrow up there that
points to a human being so you get the
size of this telescope okay now the
scientists and engineers they get it all
the time but for the rest of us you know
when you look up at the Sun you're not
seeing the Sun now you're seeing it as
it was eight million eight eight minutes
ago this telescope will allow us to see
so far in space we will see back twelve
point eight billion years in the past
about a billion years after the Big Bang
and I included this because when you get
that perspective this would this is this
is being fabricated now we're building
it in Chile with a consortium of
Smithsonian and others it'll be done in
2020 which is probably a good idiom for
foresight but the idea is to capture
that same sense of you know the
exploration humankind's human beings
have always looked up in the sky and
wondered what's the significance of all
that stuff up there for all of us down
here and this is a scientific way into
that answer so I thought I'd look and
you know American history by two objects
that look both very far into the past of
course I love the irony because the last
product the last object will allow us to
see the universe before the first object
was created spooky
okay one of the points I try to make in
this book is that the objects in this
facility and not just pretty things to
look at in cases but they're the subject
of ongoing research that our scientists
and scholars and curators do so you know
we know that among the first
paleo-indians was Clovis culture first
Clovis point when it was found came to
the Smithsonian so Sony didn't know what
to do with it we didn't really believe
at that time that ancient Indian
cultures went back that far we debate
that right now so most the conventional
theory most popular among scholars is
that North America was populated by
people coming over from Asia over right
Siberia Alaska the Bering Strait and
down that down that down the coast that
is by far the majority opinion but we
got an orrery guide in a Stanford at the
Smithsonian who's looking at these
Clovis points and you know a lot of the
Clovis points were first found in the
West well Dennis is finding him in ease
in the Chesapeake Bay and so his theory
is they may have been another migration
and some of those migrations may have
been earlier coming from the east how
can you figure in this out you got a
look at those Clovis points you got to
figure out where they're from how
they're made and so on so the stuff that
people see in cases we're actually at
night just like that movie night at the
Museum we're taking the stuff out of the
cases and looking okay as you'd expect
in the Smithsonian and in this book you
know we tell a story of American Indian
cultures and Columbus and Pocahontas and
the missions and Plymouth Rock and and
and among the things that we have in the
Smithsonian or slave shackles that tell
us do I help tell the story of slavery
when you look at these objects though as
a curator or a scholar
you're always interrogating the objects
so when you think about Pocahontas the
painting on your left represents what we
have is an engraving of Pocahontas from
1616 in the Smithsonian notice her
visage notice her cheeks the other
painting comes from about two years
later what do you notice about
Pocahontas even in the 1600s
the Brits are making Pocahontas look
whiter okay
she's Christianized and you have the
whole notion of the the civilizing
effect of colonization in America so we
look at these objects carefully and you
know what that is right
Plymouth Rock right but close to
Thanksgiving
Plymouth Rock so Plymouth Rock when the
the pilgrims got off at Plymouth it
wasn't like there was a big rock sitting
there that they got off on okay this way
Plymouth Rock was kind of manufactured
about a hundred years later 120 years
later as a kind of founding myth of the
country but you know founding myths have
an interesting thing they start becoming
real and when Alex de Tocqueville is in
America in the and writing about
American 1830s he writes well he wasn't
seriously I want to say these folk octa
Americans and Michigan Americans but but
it was something like that like you
can't believe these Americans you know
they think they landed on this rock and
now they're writing on it and turning it
into tourist Goods it became a
commercial industry okay everybody knows
what that is right
Declaration of Independence you were
looking for the coins next to your seat
when you go home tonight look at old
pictures look in the back of old picture
frames we do not have one of the missing
things people often ask me what's
missing in this book the original
Declaration of Independence now this
isn't a Nicholas Cage national treasures
movie it's real and that is when the
first exit when the declaration when
they decided on Declaration of
Independence that you know they voted on
July 2nd John Adams writes July 2nd is
going to become a great national holiday
we don't celebrate July 2nd because they
figured they needed a statement to
explain why we're doing independence
that was then voted on on July 4th
remember a guy named Tom Jefferson he
kind of drafted it on a desk we have the
desk and at the live
Congress we have his draft edited by
Benjamin Franklin very well I might add
they took they then came with a final
document they sent it over to a printer
across a street in Philadelphia guy
named Dunlap he printed up copies they
were sent to George Washington and
others and we don't know what he did
with that original copy that's why I'm
saying you might have it we have in the
Smithsonian the kind of things that tell
a story of our fight for independence
from George Washington's sword and
uniform you know that was a pretty
handsome uniform that George Washington
did and he did it because he designed it
himself he ordered the material and why
did he do that because he didn't want
the Brits to think that the Americans
were a bunch of ragtag revolutionaries
he wanted to show that we had stature we
had standing so he really spent a lot of
time thinking about this uniform now as
I was doing this book I learned a lot
I'm really not trained as a historian
and American historian I'm trying this
cultural anthropologist and so you're
kind of trained to look at objects in
wonder where they came from why there
they are the way they are why they took
the form they did anybody know what this
is do I say anybody walking stick who's
walking stick benjamin franklin's
this is the walking stick a year before
he dies Benjamin Franklin writes a
codicil in his will it writes a codicil
saying I leave this humble walking stick
to my good friend George Washington this
could have been the scepter of a king
okay instead it is a humble stick
crowned by the cap of Liberty what the
heck was Franklin talking about and I
looked at this was given to him by a
French lady oh just as the United States
won its independence and defeated the
British and this was a celebratory
present to Franklin Franklin was our
ambassador of France so I'm looking at
the gold doohickey up top on this stick
and wondering what is that it's just
some gold deck
raishin whatever so you start getting
into history and you you kind of look at
it you look at the evidence the
documentary evidence the letters and so
on when Benjamin Franklin went as our
ambassador to France he was balding it
was cold he needed a cap to wear he
brought a fur cap while the French loved
Franklin's cap at the time remember the
French are debating the same to some of
the same things the Americans are rights
of man what's the natural condition of
what's the natural human condition
what's human nature and so on the French
love Franklin because this fur cap
signal that somehow Americans coming
from this frontier place offer their
were closer to nature and it was
Franklin who was so distinguished an
inventor a scholar of great Fame and
he's wearing a fur cap so Franklin
writes his daughter you can't believe
these people I'm wearing a hat they're
making plates then making portraits than
making medallions send me more fur caps
so what is on Franklin's head what is
the cut what is the cap that is a fur
cap and Washington could have been king
this could have had a crown on it it
could have had a French powdered wig
instead it has a simple fur cap in that
one object is an encapsulation it's
almost like this DaVinci Code you know
it's almost like in that object you get
a sense of what American democracy is
about it's encoded in that one object
you know about this George Washington we
have the original portrait in the in the
Smithsonian Philadelphia has another
commissioned copy Brooklyn my hometown
has another copy the one that Dolly
Madison rolled up in the White House
when they burned the White House not
real but again when you look at a
portrait like this if you look through
the portals you know this Jewish washing
is a total made-up setting and you know
you've probably seen this iconic thing
you know as iliyan times but look over
you know his extended arm and you see
through the the portal there through the
so to speak storm clouds representing
the revolution look in the other side of
the picture and you see the rainbow the
future of the United States
so again gilbert stuart's encoding in
this this portrait of washington the
past and what he hopes is the future
aspiration of the united states now he
was a little disappointed there because
george washington doesn't look so happy
why doesn't Washington look happy he
just got a new set of false teeth so he
looks a little pained one of our
favorite most iconic objects in the
Smithsonian is the this flag not not
sewn by Betsy Ross star-spangled banner
this is the flag that flew over Fort
McHenry in that September in September
the morning of September 14 1814 Francis
Scott Key who wrote oh say can you see
you know that song we a lot of people
sung it on Saturday and Sunday at
football games across this country but
very few realize that it pertains to an
actual flag this is the flag that flew
over Fort McHenry that Francis Scott Key
out in Chesapeake Bay looked at that 40
didn't know whether he'd see the
American flag or he'd see the British
flag and however it went so in our
country and of course it was an American
flag he composed the poem that was
turned into a song that that flag was
loved to death when it came to the
Smithsonian this how he this is how it
came it was shortened by about 8 feet
you see somebody cut out a star people
cut out swatches it was loved to death
it became kind of a religious relic a
patriotic relic we had to take care of
it at the Smithsonian and we hired a
group of seamstresses led by and Fowler
she had developed a conservation
technique too so in 1.7 million stitches
into this flag putting it on linen and
therefore saving the flag well for those
of you remember visiting the Smithsonian
and as Stewart says when our good friend
Roderick candidate he was on the board
of law now and the head of the American
History Museum was head of the American
history when you came to then the flag
hung and long and we played the
star-spangled
you know at 10 and 2 and so on every day
well that hanging and the threads that
we put in to save the flag Roger and
other realized it was actually
destroying the flag and so we had to go
and take out 1.7 million stitches and
put that you see the size of that those
those those stripes are about two feet
wide and create a gantry and do this so
we could preserve that flag for the
American people so that it would it
would last and so that it would last
forever we we built a oxygen free
chamber for it so in that chamber in
case the whole in case of all the
Washington burns again in case the whole
museum goes up in flames the
star-spangled banner will be safe and we
get five million people a year that come
before that flag and what we do if you
recall the more of 1812 you know which
was a kind of funny war we don't really
know why I was thought but it was over
it was all over the issue of the British
recognizing American citizenship they
were taking people off ships and they
saying you're not American you're
British you guys serve in the British
Navy so what do we do now
well the flag again is not just the
historical artifacts we actually swear
in new citizens in what in flag whole
right in front of the star-spangled
banner so we recognize that act of
citizenship that the British were
denying back in the war of 1812 very
very moving when that happens in the
book I talk about the settlement of of
the West the frontier from the Conestoga
wagon that's largely used in the
Appalachians that develops into a much
smaller Prairie schooner to the compass
that gets Lewis and Clark across the
country it still works
it costs five dollars in the book it
costs five dollars then in the book I
talk about the cotton gin the cotton gin
you know was developed a lot of people
working on an invention it often happens
that way con gin was developed to take
this short the seeds out of cotton so it
be more efficient in terms of harvesting
and processing and eli gins cotton gin
was a great revelation the jan meaning
engine
it improved labor but also made cotton a
lot more profitable and unintended
consequences of invention what it led of
course was to the great expansion of
slavery because now you can grow a lot
more cotton
it led Andy Jackson to to kick Indians
in the south also their land because now
they'll land can be used for cotton it
led for massive growth of slavery in
this country and that fuelled northern
mills and so on it also helped fuel
these things at the Smithsonian
you know the idea is how much to collect
who stuff to collect stuff being the
technical term for the National
collections and I have this illustration
in the book we have all the patent
models and Sony got the patent models so
that was great source of collections at
the Smithsonian and here within a yet
about it within a three or four year
period look at all the different sewing
machines you get these are inventors
coming up with the solution what are
they trying to solve how do you join two
pieces of cloth together and how do you
do that in an efficient and high-quality
way and so when at the Smithsonian the
collections are not just again for show
but to help us study the process of
innovation and how inventors work to
come up with what they come up with of
course this this these sewing machines
end up sewing that great American
product jeans right ladies Strauss and
that in the first jeans are blue but
there's two types of jeans very early on
in this town in San Francisco a blue
which were from familiar with but also a
brown duck gene and we have very early
copy of that at the Smithsonian another
thing that helped build the country was
the railroads of course and we have at
the Smithsonian the John Bull this was
the first running locomotive in the US
then holpen you know cars and passengers
the guys that built this this ran all in
Jersey New Jersey
18:31 this came this is manufactured in
England but and we even have a
manufacturing capability in the United
States it came in pieces
imagine your other crew now in Jersey in
1831 you've never seen a locomotive and
they tell you to build one so they had
to assemble this locomotive but what we
have is great documentation about how
this worked because this really started
the railroad industry in the country and
really opened up the country to mass
transportation at the top of this shot
you see what the Train look like
carrying its tender and you see the
thing out in front of the Train what
happened is kind of an American story
you had an entrepreneur who wanted to
build a railway to connect New York and
Philadelphia he had to do it all through
New Jersey he laid the track very
quickly so the track wasn't laid well so
every time they put the Train on it
would derail so you had another
invention which was the thing out in
front the guide wheels that would help
keep the Train on now if you look below
that we have an a record a contemporary
of what it was like to be on this train
there's a sculptor an American sculptor
John Frazee and we got his papers later
at the Smithsonian archives of American
Art and in those papers he's writing a
letter to his wife and he draws the
trainees on he says you can't believe it
this thing is belching steam it's so
powerful it's giving me a headache
there's such noise and then it took off
like a shot 15 miles an hour
so it gives you a perspective on things
now if you look at this other photo in
the lower part you know where the train
is actually running that is not an old
time shot that's an old time that's not
an old time reenactment one of the
things you get to do with this
Smithsonian it's a lot of fun when the
curators is when the people go home you
can take the stuff out and so we had our
curators who oversee our transportation
they said in 1981 for the 150th
anniversary of that 1831 ride how bad if
we fire up that old John bull
we had a crane put it on a truck took it
out to the railroad tracks by Georgetown
by the canal we put it on there they
fired her up those are not old-time guys
there those are curators of the
Smithsonian driving that train in 1981
still worked amazing this is story I'd
like to tell and I use the book not to
get this is not a footnote a
dissertation about history but rather
telling stories about history I love
this one because the telegraph was again
the first kind of mass communication in
the United States using electricity and
so on you're familiar with the the
telegraph key at the top but the first
telegraph really has developed more as a
fax machine than a telegraph you see
that other device below and you see a
long tape there that has a message what
hath God wrought that was the first
message that Vail and Morse transmitted
back and forth to each other in
Washington Washington in Baltimore what
it is is you do the dot dash dot dash
thing right but it would imprint on
paper and so that device down below is a
register that would print out a tape and
then you'd look at the tape you'd see
the dots and dashes on the tape and then
you translate the dots into a W and an A
and a T and so on well you know what
happened again with inventions they take
interesting turns and so with the
telegraph well what happened is
telegraph operators would listen to the
stuff and they could hear dots and
dashes they didn't need to print out and
so that part of the invention disappears
out what the Telegraph was first used
for my boss's predecessor his
predecessor the first secretary of the
Smithsonian Joseph Henry was a physicist
he was very much interested in whether
in the 1840s and 1850s what he did is he
sent thermometers and barometers to
people around the country and he called
him correspondence we call him weather
buddies and he said type you his
instructions due to the temperature do
the barometric and then every morning
Telegraph to the Smithsonian what the
weather's like in Cincinnati and st.
Louis and other places he'd wake up in
the morning at a map of the United
States he'd start mapping there that
became the first weather map and the
origins of the weather service and of
course for a farming country an
agricultural economy that was vitally
important but it was the first example
of what I would call crowdsourcing and
citizen science and that led to to
understanding the weather okay
this is an interesting object it looks
pretty big up on the screen that would
be a chunk of gold
I mean Stewart if you had that Alex if
you had that long now foundation would
be doing pretty good but but it's not a
gold meteorite this this this object is
really about the size it's about
one-fifth the size of your pinky nail
and this was the flake the James
Marshall saw in January 1848 at a place
called Sutter's Mill this is the flake
that started the gold rush this was then
taken from California and delivered to
the President of the United States at
that time pulk and this is the one that
kicked everybody off to come to this
state this is why it was so crowded in
San Francisco this afternoon during rush
hour very poignant object for many of us
at the Smithsonian this is Abraham
Lincoln's hat Lincoln was a tall guy
about six foot four and the Hat gave him
more stature a lot of J of his generals
and colleagues were worried this would
make him a bigger target for people to
shoot at which they occasionally did but
the the top hat unlike the fur cap gave
people respectability and Lincoln its
signal sophistication
was a change in American life wearing of
top hats it showed you were more or bein
sophisticated and so on so Lincoln
needed that in order to deal of course
with with the country and the war
it's very poignant for me because you
see that black band going around the
middle was a black band that he put on
for his decease Willie his son Willie
who died when he was in White House 1862
and we can put this it's almost like a
badge of mourning and he did that
because the whole country was mourning
over its sons lost in the Civil War
where the North ACEF so a very public
display of what was going on at the time
Lincoln wore this hat on April 14th 1865
when he went to Ford's Theater came into
the theater placed up standing ovations
he sat down he put the hat next to him
sat in the chair and then of course he
was assassinated by John Wilkes Booth so
when we see this hat you know it has
like the perspiration stains of Lincoln
on it you could feel and touch history
when when Stewart talked about
digitisation and doing so much it's
exactly right you could have a
representation but when you look at that
hand you feel Lincoln now what we do is
we do a lot of Lincoln and Civil War
scholarship and you know sometimes you
have stuff in the Smithsonian and you
don't know quite what you have we have
this watch you see the initials on it al
this is Abraham Lincoln's gold watch
we'd already heard stories about this
about in the family there was stuff
written in Lincoln's watch we didn't
know what they believed in I well Harry
Rubinstein the curator of Lincoln's
watch you know says hey this is about
two years ago you know some we should
open that watch there's a lot of stories
about what's inside of it so he popped
open
Lincoln's watch what did we find well we
found all sorts of things written in
there I'm not sure you can read it from
there you maybe make it out you see what
the arrows pointing to it says Jeff
Davis Jefferson Davis so Abraham Lincoln
during the Civil War is carrying around
a watch that his watch repairman had
inscribed the
name of the president of the Confederacy
and so you get these wonderful cases
where you know kind of just gives you a
sense of what was what was what was
happening and and and kind of unknown
history we have many Civil War objects
that document issues of slavery and
african-american life I Harriet Timmons
Hummel and amber types were ambrotypes
of Frederick Douglass I love this little
pocket copy of the Emancipation
Proclamation really tiny little but this
is what was that Union officers took
into the field to tell people they were
freed because they would read from him
in 1863 a poignant story and something
that again we have members of the
Smithsonian family here some of the
members of our of our National Board and
other advisors who are close to the
Smithsonian but you know the Smithsonian
you know partook of American history 167
year old institution
look at that medal that is a medal that
a woman uh it's Christian Fleetwood's
Medal of Honor
Christian fleet was an African American
soldier who won the medal of honor in
the Civil War his granddaughter and
night in 1947 tried to donate it to the
Smithsonian the Smithsonian curator said
no we can't collect this African
American material it'll start a whole
collection and this isn't relevant to
American history now remember at that
time that's the museum that's your
National Museum but remember our
baseball was segregated our armies were
segregated our life was segregated and
so you know the museum in some way in
its collections reflects some of that
what we have now in the construction on
the mall is new African American history
museum and culture museum next to the
Washington Monument should be done in a
few years and you'll be amazed it's
what's coming out and what's coming into
the collection as a result of doing this
because many african-americans
throughout the country are coming forth
with things that before they would not
donate and now
and it's just amazing the types of
things we're finding this painting I
don't know a Bierstadt the the Alba you
know among the Sierra Nevada California
I don't know Shelby you're on the board
of our American Art Commission I mean
this is worth a lot of money right yeah
lots of money I mean if this is on the
market I don't know maybe it would be
worth sixty seventy eighty million
dollars in the Centers we have the large
painting Alvear Scott used to charge two
bits for people to see it back east that
is these were the paintings he came to
California painted these scenes and
these mythologized the West for people
in the east and then he'd have a a
curtain in everything and it was a great
drama to show the painting and show
people what out west looked like and it
was a way of enticing settlement
interesting stories we have at the
Smithsonian the I find anyway the the
Buffalo we had a guy at the Smithsonian
who's a taxidermist he wanted a stuffed
Buffalo in the case he didn't know what
Buffalo look like he was a guy from the
east how do you know what you know
musculature everything like that so what
does he do goes west he looks for
Buffalo couldn't find any 1880s could
not find Buffalo finally found a few
Buffalo didn't have the heart to kill
the Buffalo named one of them sandy took
them back to Washington put it in a
Corral on the mall outside of the
Smithsonian castle people loved it all
of a sudden people were coming he had to
get more animals it became Noah's Ark
that was the origin of the National Zoo
it was also the origin of the
conservation movement of realizing that
we were wiping out species and what we
gonna do about it so Hornady teamed up
with a guy named Teddy Roosevelt Bronx
Zoo and others and it led really to the
conservation movement so too did this
chap this is one of Stuart's friends
this is Martha there's a case where the
the label at for Martha in our Natural
History Museum says the last of her
species extinct Martha died at the
Cincinnati Zoo on September 1st 1914 at
1:00 p.m. it's an amazing case to know
that we know when the last of a species
died exactly
it was Martha her companion had been
George Wright George and Martha the
people at the Cincinnati Zoo put her a
nice shipped her to the Smithsonian and
at one time when you look at autobahns
writings when you look at our writings
around there were billions of passenger
pigeons Martha died there were none you
know what that is Alexander Graham
Bell's telephone look at your cell phone
this is where it began and again doing
amazing work on this so Alexander bell
left a lot of recordings and he was
fighting with Edison over recording
technology Edison won but Bella
developed stuff and he had recordings
that he deposited in the basement of the
Smithsonian and we had to figure out how
to play like a hundred years later now
thankfully we got where's Mickey Mickey
Hart here's Mickey Hart know maybe known
as the drummer for the Grateful Dead
that's how you know him but I know
Mickey as a amazing ethnomusicologist
has worked for the Smith the Smithsonian
for decades a sound engineer who's
helped us recover the sounds of early
recordings and figure out how to make
stuff available and I think it was
Mickey's influence here that when a
fellow over at Livermore the MacArthur
this year working with the Library of
Congress and the Smithsonian to
optically read and recover these sounds
so you could actually hear Alexander
Graham Bell going
little um but when you think when you
think I'm thinking long now of recording
languages and giving people in the
future an idea of what we were like you
start thinking about the preservation of
these media how to play it what
equipment you're going to need and how
that's going to work in the book I deal
with Edison's light bulb and the Model T
and the Wright brothers flyer and this
amazing object you all recognize it this
is the sugarcane
alien spacecraft this as what our
curator in American history says was the
birthplace of the polyester kingdom this
is the baked Eliezer this is some
Belgian guy came to New York and
invented something called plastic never
been exhibit at the Smithsonian I think
our curators think it's a little too
hideous but I had included in the book
it's amazing
okay another one little surprise anybody
ever hear of Bernice Palmer nobody's
heard of any sperm but you know camera
camera Bernice is a 17 year old girl she
wants a Kodak camera Kodak cameras early
1900s way of democratizing experience
anybody could document their experience
take a picture no big chemicals and all
that
Bernice Palmer's get some Brie a Kodak
camera for 17th birthday gets on a ship
to take a cruise with her mother it's
called the Carpathia there I don't
anyway I think they get it distress call
from the Titanic who has the camera
teenage girl she's the one that takes
the pictures of the iceberg it's a
little hard to read on the picture she's
the one that takes a picture of the
survivors she's the one who when they
get back to New York all the reporters
are clamoring it's her pictures that go
around the world can't be an SF Jazz
without showing some of the popular
culture stuff Louis Armstrong's trumpet
among many objects in our collection of
about 20,000 musical instruments we do
have Mickey Mouse hisself on the for
steamboat
Willie Dorothy's red slippers just very
quickly on those you know in the script
and in frank Baum's book The Wizard of
Oz they were not Ruby
they were silver the reason they became
ruby was because of the invention of
Technicolor that made them really shine
and when you stand next to them as I do
and play around with them you see
they're really more brownish and
burgundy and I have not tried on the
ruby slippers size five and a half or
six think about technology the
television said I know maybe when some
of us were smaller I when I was a kid in
the 50s I remember those art deco TV
sets but look at the TV set you didn't
watch the tube you watched the mirror
you watched your reflection another one
that Mickey worked on the recordings of
Woody Guthrie this is the original
lyrics of this land is your land that
Guthrie wrote and this is the original
acetate recording this land is your land
originally titled God blessed America
again that acetate is decomposing over
time and so one of the you know one of
the challenges how do you move from
immediate immediate immediate ooh keep
ahead of technology so you keep playing
it but you know the challenge is how do
you preserve these precious artifacts of
our history in the book I deal with
point and stuff look at the date on this
hand stamp Oklahoma December 6 1941 the
guys in the Postal Museum on the US
Oklahoma did not get a chance to change
the date that Sunday morning in Pearl
Harbor very poignant Tuskegee Flyer at
the Smithsonian that will go into the
new African American Museum that we can
do it poster right you think it's Rosie
the Riveter it's not that's apocryphal
it became mozi the Riveter but that's a
story you'll have to read I deal with
japanese-american internment certainly
in this state was very very poignant
tomorrow I'm going to a benefit for a
good friend senator Dan Inouye who
passed away earlier this year he was in
the 442 he's kind of the guy in this
picture as his wife is holding an infant
under a guard tower because she's
interned
he's losing his arm in winning the Medal
of Honor
and in the book I don't shy away from
things like the Enola Gay and tough ones
certainly the Cold War the ol Armstrong
spacesuit kind of one of my favorites
one because it was mythic here where
people might hear human beings we walked
on the moon who would have thought how
possible but the other reason I love it
is because how did it get to be that way
how did it get to be designed that way
so when they first did it it was a guy
thing
the idea was designed the spacesuit so
it was hard aluminum fiberglass you
couldn't move I'm from New York when my
mother dressed me up to go ice skating
was like this it could never move you'd
never be able to walk on a moon like
they'd first designed the spacesuit so
they held an international competition
to design the spacesuit who won
International latex corporation better
known as Playtex so as one wonderful
commentator said Neil Armstrong took a
giant step for mankind and even a larger
step for ladies girdles brassieres and
underwear but it was the notion of
layers and flexibility that allowed us
so so sometimes you have invention from
the on you know the most unimaginable
quarter that has tremendous effect in
the book I deal with the civil rights
movement from the Greensboro lunch
counter to Caesar Chavez's Union jacket
and and and short ho that was banned
here in the state the AIDS quilt we have
panels of the AIDS quilt and of course
it's been very moving something that are
originated here and to have that on the
National Mall of the United States
stretching for literally miles is I
think really affect the national
consciousness when it needed to we have
in the Smithsonian objects of popular
culture like Chuck Berry's Gibson guitar
the one he called Maybelline they won't
let me play it the Bob Dylan poster by
Milton Glaser influenced again by things
happening with the Jefferson Airplane
and Grateful Dead here in San Francisco
Marilyn Monroe's lips and one of my more
favorite objects it was delivered in
this box anybody know what that box held
humph it's under your seat look under
your seat the Hope Diamond postage Harry
Winston two dollars and 44 cents
imagine mail to the Smithsonian
Institute in Washington okay
so let me tell you and it wasn't a
publicity gimmick Harry always did that
so let you know inside story and in the
book I go behind the scenes to tell the
stuff you'll never get in the museum's
that's really the inside story
behind-the-scenes story so the Hope
Diamond
you all know Napoleon right who's a guy
in France okay so you know in the French
Revolution the French crown jewels were
looted and stole made kind of
disappeared and Napoleon in conquering
Europe wanted to get the French crown
jewels back together and reunite them
they Louie the 16th at the greatest
collection of jewels in in in the world
and one of them was this blue diamond
the French blue it was called that went
to Britain it became the Hope Diamond
later okay cut down a bit Charles de
Gaulle remember him he wanted to do what
Napoleon could not and get it back so
his guy writes to the Smithsonian and
say hey we like that Hope Diamond if you
can loan it to an exhibit at the Louvre
well what do you think we said at the
Smithsonian are secure ators right we're
not dumb like what are you kidding I
mean we were lighting everything but we
weren't gonna loan the goal the hope so
who did he go to to get him to get the
Smithsonian to do the Hope Diamond he
goes to the lady living in a white house
down the block is 1962 by the name of
Jackie Kennedy so Jackie Kennedy calls
the head of the Smithsonian and says I
would like you to send the Hope Diamond
to France the head of the Smithsonian is
at the plactic well it's it's the
biggest showstopper in the Smithsonian
people are coming you know I think it's
cursed as always stories whatever so he
doesn't know what to do so he calls the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court who
serves
the Chancellor of the Smithsonian that
guy in 1962 is a Californian by the name
of Earl Warren he says do I have to
listen to Jackie the chief justice's yes
what are we gonna do with the
Smithsonian so we do what only a good
curator would think to do we take no we
didn't send a fit hey we all stuff at
this Smithsonian marielle stuff we
decide you look in your curatorial
manual and they are in Chapter 5.3 it
says if they want something that you
don't want to give take a hostage so we
say we'll give you a hug diamond a you
got something we'd like you to loan to
us so we sent the Hope Diamond to the
Louvre and the French sent to us a
interesting lady with an enigmatic smile
by the name of Mona Lisa in the museum
we have Julia Child's kitchen our
curators went up there Julia Child great
your introduction your French cook a
woman who broke the the male Chef line
and Julia Child we went up there to
collect a few things let's get a few
pots and pans some of her French things
whatever the curators were so taken by
Julia Child's curation they said we have
to collect the whole kitchen including
the kitchen sink and that's what we did
so that's come to the come to the
Smithsonian
we have McDonald's arches to the
illustrate American globalization and
r2d2 today I was down looking at the
Computer History Museum down in Mountain
View we have the original ENIAC and as a
piece of it there just imagine this is a
computer there were 48 in fact it was a
computer you did not compute on you
computed in you in you really bend and
at first computer referred to females
who did mathematical calculations they
were the computers and of course we have
the the
a Macintosh computer we have objects of
media based arts and I was talking to
Stuart before this was done by Nam June
Paik and really helped articulate the
notion of the electronic superhighway
look at all that neon and the notion of
movement and so on but it's all done
with tubes and things that are not made
anymore so here you have media based
arts and when you start thinking maybe
we'll send this to the long now
foundation to take care now our head of
Smithsonian American Art Museum would go
ballistic if I suggested that I did not
say that take that off the table but you
have a real problem the artist intended
this to be driven by the technology and
machinery of the time and yet the
machinery and technology of time is
disappearing these bulbs burn how do we
preserve the artwork it's a it's a very
interesting problem
this one PCR machine that's what it
looks like that's what enables the
reproduction of the DNA and it has
tremendous consequences as we know in
terms of our society now sometimes we
collect things at the Smithsonian they
have a purpose at one period of history
it changes over time you remember the
Miracle on the Hudson plane went down
bird strike whenever there's a bird
strike in the country they take the bird
pet a I don't want to disturb your
dessert here bird pate from the engine
they send it to the Smithsonian so we
can figure it out that person in charge
of that project forensic or anthology is
a woman whose name is Carla dove she's
the one that has to figure out what
birds hit the plane so we could prevent
it in the future
she's the one that says how Canadian
geese blame it on the Canadians but it's
made possible by the peace your machine
and so that happened on the mirror you
know the the flight with the Hudson and
this is the data set we have to do it
millions and millions of birds so if we
can't identify it by DNA we're using
feathers we're using beaks we're using
other body parts to figure out what bird
hit it at the Smithsonian we have things
that tell very poignant stories like a
piece of the Berlin Wall obviously we
collected
after 9/11 the fire engines of first
responders and coins from the Pentagon
and a flight log from a flight attendant
went down at Shanksville on 93 shilling
from the World Trade Center a tough
curators like to collect the good stuff
this is a very tough collection effort
we also have and I want to include in
the book the fact you know the earliest
objects documenting American culture
American Indian but I want to make the
point that American Indians are indeed
still around
and so object number 100 was a totem
pole still be done today by David Box
Lee using new technology but telling
traditional stories and keeping alive an
artform that helps tell his his his
community's stories now things come to
us in amazing ways at the Smithsonian I
know you're all anxious to donate
everything you have to the Smithsonian
the we had a delivery what two years ago
of one object it was the space shuttle
discovery came in over Washington on 747
we had the enterprise named by all of
Star Trek fans that have been in the
Smithsonian the test vehicle for the
shuttle program we put both shuttles
back Nick you know nose to nose we had
about 40 astronauts including John Glenn
it was an amazing amazing a spectacle
and that space shuttle is now in the
Smithsonian
now some stuff is you know driven in or
flown in other things come to us in
other ways you'll remember the pandas
they came to us from China anybody
remember what the US gave the Chinese in
return for the pandas milkman and
Mathilde Oh Milton Mathilde muskox
we got pandas we gave them musk ox we
got the better of the deal but you know
when you get pandas and you get two
pandas you often get other acquisitions
to your collection like 71a the baby
panda now now is Stuart intimated at the
Smithsonian we're increasingly digital
and you know like other institutions at
first you have websites and you take
pictures of what's in your collection
and then you start using it I'm really
partial to that LeafSnap thing because
it made me sound so intelligent we
zillions of leaves at the Smithsonian
and so we did a database for them you do
an app and then you're out walking with
your kid and the kid says daddy what
kind of tree is that hold up your phone
take a picture of the leaf that
references the Smithsonian collection
all of a sudden you say oh it's a blue
ash originally from Minnesota I mean you
know kind of know everything so it gives
people access to our collections we're
doing a lot of crowdsourcing we have
four curators of philately and six
million stamps physics problem if they
algebra problems they work for how many
years to catalogue every stamp
impossible but what we're doing is
crowdsourcing that among philatelist so
they could help us do research we're
increasingly using digitization to
enhance our exhibition collections and
this one I love because what we did we
had a collection of Buddhist sculptures
from caves from China
we had the sculpture in the Smithsonian
the Chinese had the caves but the caves
were all looted and gone we were able to
recreate the caves and then put the
sculpture from the museum in situ in the
museum creating that gallery so you can
really understand where what role they
occupied as you saw we're increasingly
digitizing our collection it's not easy
it's not flat it's not as easy as Google
in terms of Google Books or flat things
flat scanning because you have to scan
as you saw with the gunboat philadelphi
at the beginning complicated objects
you're imaging you know complex skeletal
remains layers of sculpture but we're
finding that it's pretty good to print
stuff we could actually print Thomas
Jefferson
you know Monticello couldn't lend us the
statue they have of Jefferson so we just
printed our own and you can start
studying things so you know the Wright
brothers if you go to the Smithsonian
and even our curators can't get that
detail eagle eye view of how the Wright
brothers really flew but you start doing
this high-resolution digital technology
and you could study you know the
mechanics of the Wright brothers craft
innovation we're doing an interesting
thing Danny Hillis is here from the long
now foundation he has a buddy bran
Ferren who were working with now and
Shelby Gans again from our Commission on
at the Smithsonian American Art Museum
we have this gallery next to the White
House in Washington right on
Pennsylvania the the Renwick gallery and
basically what we're looking to is the
possibility of turning this into a
digital gallery so you can experience
things in a different way with very very
high resolution or works in that gallery
and it could change so at two o'clock
it could be a gallery of world
portraiture but at 3 o'clock you could
change it into a streetscape and do it
for performance or what I as a cultural
historian really love is that you can
make the walls of the museum disappear
and you could look at Washington and you
can look at Washington in 1960 we could
look at Washington in 1880 or 1834 you
can have an event inverse in the you
know Palace of Versailles or in the Taj
Mahal so increasingly doing that kind of
thing the use of digitization and then
finally what I love and again my wife
the the schoolteacher says Richard I
love taking my kids to the Smithsonian I
can't doing you know time what are you
gonna do to bring the Smithsonian to my
classroom she's in Virginia what do I
tell teachers in Iowa or in Alberta or
in Korea or in Chile and my answer is
with 3d printing you too can own the
Hope Diamond you can print it out you
can print out George Washington sort of
Benjamin Franklin and use objects as the
monic device is to teach about history
science technology art and so on I just
tell my wife when we develop that really
fully develop that just remember when
you're pushing the when you're gonna
recreate the Space Shuttle remember to
push the reduce button but I think the
idea of bringing the collections
bringing the value of the collections to
teachers around the country and people
and around the world is a great thing
again nothing like seeing
real thing it's heavy hefty but
important but there's nothing like
seeing the real thing but if you can't
see the real thing to try to give people
a visceral experience of what that's
about
so why don't I stop there and I think we
have some questions Alex and glad to
take questions and thank you very much
have a seat I'm chortling because the
first question is what are these objects
of our past you know no name here about
our present the future have you thought
about America's future and hundred and
two objects we're having a speaker next
year who's doing the future and hundred
objects mm-hmm so you only have to
answer that one for someone else well
well now I I kind of do look I have to
answer this all the time you know like
how come you didn't include the teddy
bear and how come you didn't include
more things of popular culture from the
presents and why isn't far being there
and then I have to deal with Stephen
Colbert who donated his portrait to the
Smithsonian a while ago we hung it in
the men's room and the portrait down we
did accession it and I'm sure he's gonna
quiz me on why it's not in the hundred
and one I got a coffee cup from your
show when I was they said you can't take
that and I said well actually I'm going
to take it that's what they do see they
believe it's only valuable if Pat Tufts
asks what is the most famous object
where the popular understanding of it is
completely wrong and maybe most
interesting provenance what you've told
a lot of stories here but yeah there's
stuff that people have notions about and
museums are partly to reward notions but
also partly to undermine notions there
are some of the good undermining well
you know I mean there's a story and I
think the one with the Declaration of
Independence people go and they they
view what they think is the original
copy of the Declaration of Independence
is not and then they take the copy that
they buy that parchment they unroll it
and they think that's you know a real
facsimile of the real Declaration of
Independence and of course that was made
in 1823 oops
after the fact and the declaration
independence wasn't signed on July
some people didn't sign till August and
September in November so you know what
it introduces you get something like
that it's so iconic and so basic what
are you telling me July 4th is it you
know really this and they didn't sign it
that day and all of that and it you know
kind of exposes people to the kind of
nuances of history what was going on we
were Rory fighting a war we didn't begin
the war afterwards you're only fighting
for a year so we got we get stuff like
that out of history so we do fireworks
on July 4th what should we do on July
2nd yeah well celebrate John Adams day
Katherine as everyone is wondering what
objects were close but didn't make the
cut I was there for a whole lot of
people involved in what was involved in
this and and you made the final cut or
how did that work well I what I did is I
consulted with a lot of my curators
around the institution and different
museums and people have their
suggestions and as you can imagine
people have strong opinions so we have a
National Postal Museum you know we have
philatelists they sent me over lists
like why can't everything be a stamp
right I think they sent the hundred so I
had to choose one you know well anyway
we had a lot of people doing that so I
got a lot of suggestions from my fellow
curators what I relied on a lot was the
American people you know we get 30
million people come to our museums every
year we get another of a hundred million
that come online and what do they
gravitate to and so you take that into
consideration and then there were things
where I just ignored everybody and
included some objects like the baked
eliezer and like the Kodak camera
because I thought you know it's a
wonderful story that really nobody knew
about and wasn't that obvious plus she
had already done the whole book and the
Hope Diamond does it yes I had to
include that that was a little partial
on the opposite question will pain has
subsided to the original declaration of
independence what objects lost the
history do you wish was in the
Smithsonian clay what objects do other
people have well that's the thing if you
go through the book there's a lot of
objects from other museums I don't want
to take it away from those museums I
mean
kind of a lot of museums in this country
and they should have those items so what
I do in the book for example in talking
about the the John Bull locomotive I
talked about okay the joining of the
Transcontinental Railroad from Terry
Point and that that Golden Spike is a
few miles from here down at the at
Stanford's Museum right so we don't have
the golden spike in the Smithsonian I
kind of like it if we did but it's kind
of cool it's somewhat safe so but I do
include a picture and description and a
discussion of that object from other
museums about lost to history what are
the ones that you just wish would turn
up from somebody's basement gee that is
that is that is tough I think you know a
lot of letters get lost you know a lot
of documents like that get lost you you
wish you had all the stages of some
inventions that you know very often and
we see this I was just down at the
Computer History Museum and talking
about how they got their collection and
they said you know the their their view
anyway was that the companies there were
just as prone to moon always thinking
ahead so oh that's the model we didn't
you know throw that out and it's often
the engineers that we're developing
those and said I worked on that you know
that was my thought I put my heart and
soul in than that you can't throw that
out and so they find at that Museum they
said to me about 95 percent of the
computer stuff circuit boards I mean
circuitry machines and so on it's
actually donated by the people who
worked in the industry who kept it put
it in the garage
put it in their basement and then later
donate it to Z because they thought it
was important to document their role in
history I think that's that's always
important you said stuff is turning out
for the new african-american museum
which is taking shape I guess is that
gonna be on the mall yeah right next to
the Washington Monument what kind of
stuff is turning up from people as well
as I said well you know Harry you know
it's kind of amazing you know letters
George Washington Carver Booker T
Washington but Harriet Tubman's hymnal I
mean here Harriet Tubman was influenced
very early on and working the
Underground Railroad
by an experience she had we think it's
probably seizures as something she
as a religious experience its very
religious lady and here's her hymnal you
know that really inspired I mean you
know scores of people to freedom and all
of a sudden that turned up last year and
we we got it they the Tuskegee flyer
great story there's a ex Air Force guy I
think out of Minneapolis him and his
wife bought this flyer in an auction is
all beat up the story was it been used
as a crop duster they wanted to fly they
wanted to go to fly shows they start
restoring the plane in a way they wanted
to do it for these shows I mean the guy
figured you know I better check the
serial number and see what this is it
turns out it was one of the original
Tuskegee trainers he's completely
switched course he then designed the
mission the the plane as a Tuskegee
Flyer as it was in the 1940s he then
went to the ski airmen reunions
he had Tuskegee Airmen flying the plane
he'd take him up as a biplane you know
with passenger seat for the instructor
it used to be they'd sign the plane and
then he made his last flight he said my
god this is bigger than me he did his
last flight he went from Tuskegee
Alabama any fluid to Washington to
donate it to the Smithsonian so you know
you get stories like that you know
people feel part of history they feel
they want to share that I think it's a
great a great impulse and you know we
always point to Smithsonian know this
country and did it this is a country
that prides itself on volunteerism that
people do and solve problems and you
know increasingly with government the
way it is you know it's hard but I think
we can never lose sight of the fact that
we as citizens get together to actually
try to solve problems and do the right
thing and do the good thing and we see
it every day at this facility
you know something about objects that
they have hidden aspects and that your
story of Lincoln's watch is an eyesore
you finally open it up and look at that
Jeff Davis and I can tell you one that
is going to prove valuable which is
Martha the last passenger pigeon that
you have that is you know standard
taxidermy it's the skin and feathers and
there she is pretty well mounted ugly
bird but she was really the guy's little
baby guy the guy passenger yeah George
better dressed they have pigeons usually
are not usually dimorphic but passenger
version sorry but the cool thing is that
when Martha was shipped in a block of
ice from Cincinnati Zoo down to you guys
they only kept the skin they kept the
body and the guts in those guts is a
very important thing which we need to
study which is the microbiome the pigeon
poop that hasn't been pooped out yet
to find out what how passenger pigeons
actually ran their digestive system
because if we're going to recreate the
passenger pigeon using a band-tailed
pigeon we would like to know you know
how to basically recreate the microbiome
of that and you guys have the data and
you didn't know it bishop utopia there's
another story here I mean we've talked
about this Michael Lane mark-ass is a
digital artist so would you advise
digital artists to reconsider the value
of physical stuff and how would you
advise any of them to fight you guys
broke your butts it looks like to try to
reproduce the antiquated television sets
there's all kind of idiot out there that
you can't play unless you have you know
all of the apparatus now what do you
guys do about that well well you know we
did an exhibit at the American Art
Museum about video art and video games
we actually took a little heat from that
you know to do that in the Smithsonian
American Art Museum but I think it was a
choice and a good choice by our curators
because our changes you know our takes
on different forms and I think we wanted
to recognize that digital art in the
digital artistry and design that goes
into these museums are very very
successful exhibition at the at the
Museum so we are collecting we are
collecting digital art we're collecting
code we're collecting a lot of things
that's it the challenge is how to how to
kind of capture that and not not change
it so we had an exhibit at the Hirshhorn
about two years ago or called the cinema
effect
and to do the exhibit you know we
created galleries we had it was kind of
smoky that's when people still smoke
than theatres and we had projectors
running and those of you who remember
film remember that sound of the film
going through yeah I mean it's such a
feeling it creates such an ambience and
so we had to do that well try to find
those films now with with Mickey Hart
over here you know who's really helped
us engineer a lot of the old recordings
that we have at the Smithsonian and the
library Congress you started thinking
okay you need the machines to play those
recordings you know just think if you
have wax cylinder recordings if you have
tinfoil you know they when the early
experimentation with bill and Edison was
on all sorts of media and just like you
guys well you know you know I don't know
whether you take it as experimental or
not the different media you know but it
is experimental you don't know what the
next bit of technology is gonna be so
you know you invest in a certain
technology and then you realize oh that
was Betamax you know that was a pompom
if it wasn't worth investing so it kind
of moves so what we have to do with the
Smithsonian what's interesting is we
expect Betamax to live on in the museum
even though it doesn't live in ok you
wish but we did a Betamax player and you
need a wire recorder player and you need
something you can play selling the
recordings and so on so you we end up at
the Smithsonian keeping a whole
inventory of these machines well ok next
step so next generation you inherit
these machines you have rows and rows in
the Smithsonian and and if you have any
deaths this Messiah has 19 national
museums we have 850 buildings where to
keep all that 137 million things it's
just like that scene you remember the
last scene and Indiana Jones you know
that's exactly what it's like so now you
have rows and rows now you have an old
recording machine and you're interested
in what the Navajo language sounded like
in the 1890s yep don't play it but you
needed you not only need a machine you
need people have the knowledge to play
the machine you have people that have
knowledge to fix the machine and so
that's it now we had a guy at the
library Congress Sir John Howe Mickey
work with
work with he was like here we go to flea
markets
he'd look around for old pieces of stuff
he would jerry-rigged stuff in the
basement Library of Congress to be able
to play these old machines he passed
away rather suddenly and unexpectedly he
really hadn't trained someone and so
liked it so those old novels and it's
like human kind you know where you have
a kind of oral history and you have to
pass something on and we take a lot of
that for granted
but a lot of our knowledge is Laurel is
passed on in that way and if you don't
do it you can lose it and that we lose
language is look how many languages
we're losing every year in the world
because of that see a little bit about
the ongoing research in the world that
the Smithsonian is feeling because you
know we got that Smithson said he wanted
to know Lee the diffusion of knowledge
but in a sense the creation of knowledge
and so I'm aware of you know the you
have the laboratories in Central America
and things like that how much of the
Smithsonian is scientific research not
just having to do with museum usually is
huge we have 500 people in Panama okay
who do research on tropical biology we
own islands in the Panama Canal and the
Atlantic in the Pacific and we're
studying everything from coral reefs to
you know the movement of organisms
between the Atlantic and the Pacific
because of the canal or the Panama Canal
or work that goes back to the days of
the Panama Canal and trying to
understand the diseases that are
affecting workers so that that facility
alone gets I think some were about 900
researchers from around the world who
take up residences and our laboratories
and field sites in Panama to try to
understand and it's very interesting in
terms of speciation the environment you
know now we're dealing a lot with you
know the Frog virus it's known all the
frogs because he have a point of Panama
you have a thin spit of land that
connects two continents right North and
South America and it also connects two
oceans in a very small area so that the
idea of biodiversity within that very
small space that's great leads to a
whole slew of scientific research that
generates you know scores and scores
papers and publications and so on
similarly what a lot of people don't
know when I showed you the telescope
it's not just what building the
telescope we have 350 astrophysicists
that operate the telescope and others if
you go to the Big Island of Hawaii and
go on Mauna Kea the smithsonian facility
up there with telescopes and there we're
trying to understand the origins of the
universe we're trying to understand
black holes we're trying to understand
cosmic energy we run actually the
smithsonian one six satellites for nasa
so we actually you know have guys with
t-shirts and joysticks you know running
satellites to and gathering the data and
doing experiments and you know driving
devices into the sun I was up at the
facility
we are location of that our chief
location of that is up at with Harvard
in Cambridge and you know they were
showing me I mean we do real-time
representations of the Sun I mean huge
you know and you're standing there in a
basement you know in Cambridge and all
of a sudden you're seeing on the screen
this solar flare coming out of the Sun
you know for millions of miles and
you're ready to duck and cover but but
we monitor things like that and it's
important we monitor it so that because
that has an effect on cell phones that
has an effect on navigation its effect
on all sorts of other things we do a lot
with wildlife in speciation so I mean
we've been the leaders in panda
reproduction and figuring it out we do a
lot of work we've been doing a lot of
work the last few years on avian flu we
have a lot of burnt all those birds so
you understand the disease vector so
there's a tremendous amount and that
just touches it and that's a sign you
know it just touches the surface in
science from studying meteorites and
species and other things to our cultural
studies of you know history of art
history and so on and various cultural
field so it's pretty it's it's a lot
yeah
that's saying our art to zoo we say and
the zoo so I can have a flashback to the
Library of Alexandria which is really a
museum yeah and was also in a sense the
first University it was just some
expecting her
mainly a research university are you
guys a better model of how a university
ought to be well you know it's kind of
interesting because we have
relationships with you know scores and
scores of universities around the world
and we do a lot of teaching and you know
a lot of us hold you know what's this
Hey public interview to me way ahead of
MOOCs and all that I guess I'm teaching
the general public I think that's that
that is the thing and the issue is you
know where do museums rest in that you
know in some ways we do very formal
things I mean we get you know about a
1200 interns a year that come from
universities all over the world we get
postdocs and pre dogs that senior
postdocs who come to the Smithsonian who
work there I think the issue in terms of
30 million people who come through the
doors and another hundred million
hopefully up to a billion that will come
online is it's hard to measure certain
things about it now if you're doing
something like a formal course you know
we can give everybody all you people
come to the Smithsonian you get it get a
test when you come in the doors and test
when you leave would be a little hard to
do it's hard to measure inspiration and
I think one of the things that we do do
is you never can tell it's kind of
unpredictable about whether you know
somebody's gonna see something in the
Smithsonian and just a spark of
creativity is going to be engendered by
that exhibit and that's going to cause
them to go home and do something right
you know that year the year after or
years later so we have a hard time kind
of measuring that impact and the as far
as inspiration but as far as formal
education we have you know to race to
the top grants we work a lot in schools
across the country we work a lot with
teachers of the year across across the
United States I think one of the things
on education is we feel that we do
hands-on you know object based
participatory involved you want to teach
somebody how to invent the rocket ship
build one mm-hmm and so I think we're in
that end of the business and I think
what we've seen with No Child Left
Behind in this country is an orientation
more toward you know rote memory what's
the name of this
that and the kind of creativity
exploration discovery failure success
kind of going out of the education
business at least in the primary and
secondary school environment and that
that's kind of distressing to us like
ian was something you told me about in
the car come over here about when there
was there was a not the secret project
no no not to see the was it a poor
people's March in Washington or yeah I
was telling Stewart back because I was
talking about my origins at the
Smithsonian and when I came I was
recruited by a guy Dylan Ripley who's
pretty patrician a New England family
was in the OSS with Julia Child and
Ceylon he loved a sentence like that
Dylan who I knew very well I did
electronic he's an ornithologist the
Margaret Mead and Gregory Bateson role
so anyway so Dylan that me brought a
tuxedo so when the Japanese surrendered
he would have be properly dressed with
it succeed that type of guy but when the
poor people when there was poor people's
March in Washington 68 okay the some of
the directors of the Smithsonian came to
him and said let's close the museums
these are poor people they're uneducated
they're gonna dirty the museums people
will take stuff they're gonna fill them
all as a boy I was Phil most protest on
the mall this is following the Martin
Luther King March a several years before
people built the poor people's City
there was a village of the month and and
so directors had closed the Smithsonian
who are these people and Dylan Ripley as
patrician as he was said my god no these
are Americans too and they don't usually
visit the Smithsonian and we have a duty
to them and not only when you're not
going to close the museums we're going
to keep the museums open all night and
people said well they'll go to the
bathroom they'll get water and he said
yeah that's the point and while they're
going to bathroom and while they're at
the water fountains they might see a
sculpture of Shiva in the art museum you
know with four arms or six arms or eight
arms and they might get interested in
and we too have a role in awakening
their curiosity just like we do any
other so they kept they actually kept
the museum's open 24 hours a day it was
it was I think a high point for the you
know sometimes museums could be looked
at as the latest and you're always
protective and kind of like we wore with
Charles to go on the Hope Diamond but
III think it's a different day and I
think the idea is to share knowledge and
really be true to that original idea
that knowledge plus the democratization
of knowledge equals a progressive and
better society 24/7 open source thank
you Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you